قال رئيسه كيا شفتيه باردواني ان
التعديلات الدستوريه التي اجرتها السويد
لا تكفي لمعالجه مخاوي في تركيا قال
اردوغان في حديثه مع وسائل الاعلام انه لا
يمكن لتركيا التعامل مع عضويه السويد في
الناتو بايجابيه بينما يواصل الارهابيون
مظاهراتهم هناك وافقى تعبيره
وذكرت الرئاسه وتركيا ان الاليه المشتركه
الدائمه المشكله في اطار مذكره التفاهم
التي وقعتها تركيا وفنلندا والسويد خلال
قمه النيتو في 2022 ستعقد اجتماعها الرابع
بحضور كبير مستشاريه الرئيس التركي السفير
عاطف شاغطي اضافت ان مدير المكتب الخاص
للامين العام
والسكرتيره وزاره الخارجيه السويديه
والسكرتير وزاره الخارجيه الفنلنديه
يشاركون في الاجتماع
من انقره مراسله الجزيره المعتز بالله حسن
معتز بالله اذا المنتظر وفق هذه التصريحات
التي سبقت الاجتماع
لا محمد نحن هنا في القصر الرئاسي في
العاصمه التركيه انقره من الواضح ان
الموقف التركي ما زال هو اي على ما هو
عليه بالنسبه الى السويد قبل الاجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه هنا في
تركيا نذكر ان فنلندا كانت انضمت الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي بحفل كبير ووقتها كانت تركيا
قد وافقت على انضمام فنلندا رغم ان ملف
انضمام كل من السويد وفنلندا كانوا ملفا
مشتركا ولكن انقر قالت وقتها ان فنلندا
استجابت للمطالب التركيه ولكن السويد لم
تستجب واجر هذا الموضوع الى ما بعد
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في تركيا
اليوم هناك الاجتماع الرابع
هذا الملف هنا في تركيا برئاسه مستشار
الرئيس التركي او الناطق باسمي رئاسه
الجمهوريه وهذا الملف هو يناقش انضمام او
الخطوات التي تقوم بها السويد فيما يتعلق
بموافقه انقره انضمامها الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي لكن الجواب جاء واضحا قبل قليل من
التصريحات غير المتلفزه حتى الان للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في طريق عودته من
اذربيجان اردوغان تحدث انه لا يتوقع موقفا
مختلفا
السويدة لا تتوقع موقفا مختلفا من تركيا
في القمه المقبله قمه الناتو المقبله
خصوصا وانها الى الان ما زالت لم تستجب
بشكل كامل الى المطالب التركيه وعلى
السويد انتفي بتعهداتها وان من تصفهم
انقره بالارهابيين هم ما يزالون في شوارع
السويد وذلك في اشاره الى المظاهرات التي
تقول انقره ان انصار حزب العمال
الكردستاني المصنف منظمه ارهابيه في كل من
تركيا واوروبا والولايات المتحده ما زال
انصار حزب العمال الكردستاني بحسب انقره
يقومون بمظاهرات في السويد والسويد لا
تقوم باي شيء تجاه ذلك وبالتالي الموقف
التركي تجاه السويد مازله على
موقف الرفض من انضمام السويد حتى في
تعهداتها وذلك بحسب الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردو المعتز بالله حسن من انقره شكرا
جزيلا لك